oh it's a fumbling noise car tester yen
Stratman is taking the new Skoda Superb
for a spin the first-generation debuted
in 2001 the second in 2008 and now comes
the third does it live up to its name
the superb is the Czech car makers top
of the range model with more than
700,000 units sold to date it's holding
its own on the international market more
than 15,000 suburbs have been registered
in Germany annually since 2012 now Scott
is hoping to add another chapter to its
success story
Imelda lobby of Skoda explains that the
superb is SCOTUS flagship it brings
together everything the brand stands for
such as space and unique emotional
design Skoda aims to accentuate that
even more with this new model SCOTUS
marketing is dignified and restrained
they highlight the suburbs clear lines
characteristic elegance perfect
proportions and bi-xenon headlights
the Lauren and Clement addition on her
school is 120 year history with
confidence and pride the company's
founders both named VAT Slav established
the principle only the best is good
enough for our customers the annoyance
yen says the new Skoda Superb has all
sorts of options including a range of
assistant systems one you must have is
the dynamic chassis control an adaptive
suspension that can be set to standard
sport or comfort there's also an eco an
individual driving mode
the traffic jam assist is a combination
of lane departure warning and distance
control systems even it speeds less than
65 km/h the superb can keep to its lane
and brake automatically if the car ahead
slows down and it can't accelerate when
traffic allows that but the driver has
to have both hands on the steering wheel
as long as the car is moving the suburbs
interior has the same quality
workmanship as its VW cousins
just like the skoda fabia the superb can
present smartphone content on its
infotainment display whether from an
android or apple iOS
yeah that's done yen says the new
suburbs wheelbase is 8 centimeters
longer it's also 5 centimetres wider
that makes for a spacious interior and
good legroom he could almost dance a
tango back here income from the scooter
Supremes trunk can be kicked open you
got your hands full you can open the
tailgate with a tap of the toe
there's 625 litres inside expandable by
pulling levers to the left and right
which gives you 760 litres but you have
to pull the head rest up a bit to
flatten the bed lovely and so to sum up
it's a luxury sedan and cargo hauler yen
says only a Skoda Superb station wagon
can top it
but car buyers who can't wait for Skoda
to roll out a station wagon will be
happy with a sedan in Germany it starts
at a bit under 25,000 euros
you